right here with reaction former House
Oversight Committee Chairman former
state and federal prosecutor never lost
the cases of prosecutor Fox News
contributor trey Gowdy is with us all
right you watch this now I think I know
the federal rules of evidence correct me
counselor if I'm wrong here but they
don't allow hearsay witnesses and short
of an expert witness or - I assume
opinion witnesses will not be warranted
in a Senate trial presided over by the
chief judge of the Supreme Court Justice
of the Supreme Court yeah I don't think
the senators care what three con law
professors to the extent they can stay
awake while three con law professors
testify I don't think they care about
whether or not those three con law
professors think this president should
be removed from office hearsay
ordinarily is not admissible there are
certain exceptions
senator grave and now we're talking
about it just the other night on the
phone you can get certain hearsay in but
look Shawn the record is already
complete they've already called all
their witnesses ironically enough the
House Judiciary didn't call a single
solitary fact witness they called more
fact witnesses for the Watergate
impeachment with John Dean than they did
for the Trump impeachment so the record
is already in its full let's vote send
it to the jury list vote I will tell now
I can't see could be persuaded either
way and that I actually think these
people are so nuts that a once let the
house representative whoever they you
point to present this to the Senate let
him do whatever they want to do and then
once they have the votes the 51 votes I
would assume call a roll get it out of
there but then investigate the
whistleblower then the congenital liar
shift then hunter and Joe if we really
care about quids and pros and quos then
Joe is right there yeah what I tell
clients is you could say whatever you
want when the trial is over you want to
say something about the judge you want
to say something about the police you
want to say something about the anyone
but wait until the verdict is in and the
president is not going to be removed
from office he's not going to be
convicted on these articles so my advice
to him with
get acquitted and then you can go say
whatever you want to the Democrats and
the media two different things hunter
and Joe quid-pro-quo Joe and the
congenital liar Schiff and contact that
his office may have had likely had with
the whistleblower not whistleblower
hearsay whistleblower and the
whistleblower non whistleblower they
should all be investigated and there are
other means to do that short of doing it
within the impeachment trial confines
yeah I can't think of a worse way to
investigate something than to have
Congress do it so the house housing
ethics committee if they want to bring
Adam up for that ridiculous pair about
the cellar
or I don't staff wouldn't yeah I don't
see I mean quite candidly I don't see
Lindsay doing that I mean if there's
representations made well you've talked
to him more recently than I have but I
don't see I think once the president is
found not guilty acquitted then the
attention turns to 20/20 in November and
the president has the biggest bully
pulpit in the world if he wants to make
a point make it but make it as someone
who's been acquitted on two articles of
impeachment don't make a germ that TRO
me ask you one last question right now
don't mess it up I agree with that last
question you hear Joe Biden saying
you're not getting the billion dollars
unless you fire the prosecutor he knew
that the prosecutor he wanted fired was
investigating his zero experience son
that's being paid millions that sounds
like a potential crime to you sir I
would need to know more about it but I
would also tell you this I have a ton of
confidence in bill Bar and if there's a
factual predicate and what we learn from
Horowitz is that factual predicate
doesn't have to be too high to
investigate something if there is a
factual predicate let the professionals
do it I just don't think Congress has
acquitted itself well since I've been
following it when it comes to seriously
investigating matters let the
professionals do it if there's a
predicate for doing so all right now by
the way I know for a short time you
weren't a fox
contributor I am advocating the full
complete reinstatement at a raise for
you
trey Gowdy thank you thank you I will
have you be my agent
thank you you make a good choice if you
chose me I'm kidding